freunde herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video wir drehen heute ein tag
essen wie in kolumbien und nicht alleine
sondern auch eine ganz besondere art und
weise wir haben nämlich heute eine
gastgeberin ein vip-gast und zwar
margarita kommen gerne mal ins bild
margareten ist kolumbianerin und auch
die mama von erics freundin und sie hat
uns heute eingeladen und wird uns durch
den tag führen und wir erleben wirklich
authentisch heute einmal die in
kolumbien gegessen wird was gibt es zum
frühstück
und dann muss das ist heuer mit
symptomatik und dann aber mit ich habe
schon gehört mit was ist mit den kakao
ihr merkt schon drauf es ist alles ein
bisschen anders heute aber ich freue
mich unheimlich darauf ich freue mich
auch dass mir das heute zeigst weil ich
weiß es sehr zu schätzen tut was sagen
wir dann einfach an mit dem
was sind die zutaten
ein bisschen zug und ein bisschen sagt
einmal warmes wasser
warm laufen ja wenn du magst kannst du
einfach mal loslegen ich guck dir dazu
und vielleicht kann ich dann selbst auch
welche machen wenn ich es mir zutraue
vermag
keine waage das macht man alles nach
gefühlten ja sagen wie viel zu heiß das
besondere zucker ist und dann auch hier
und auch nicht zu wenig da dachte ich
mir schon das für geschmack muss
ordentlich dass man hat auch das gefühl
der teig an sich ist gar nicht so schwer
also es ist relativ einfach einfache
zutaten und schnell gemacht ja ja ja ja
ist das frühstück was man jeden tag ist
ja falls ihr denn da machen
ich komme aus cali ist meine stadt und
wir essen auch ein der bonus zum
fürchten das ist auch mit
aber viele leute machen ohne käse weil
es alle sein ist es aber wenn die sowohl
das essen die machen entwickelte auf die
kette ja
sowas aber ich mache
kannst du dir natürlich gerne gesagt
gestoppt
ok ok wechsel das ist so die eingebaute
die waage ist in den augen siehst du
jetzt ja jetzt hat doch so schwer
konsistenz und gibt hier nur so eine
schöne saftig okay jetzt geht's rund
ok
ich doch ein bisschen nicht
durch diese technik wie gekonnt das
großwerden den so kosten ja machen nicht
gar nicht drauf und da machen wie eine
schmale und klein aber nur die noch
befüllen möchtest dann noch so ein
bisschen der
rollwiderstand soja muss das hier ist
und dann ein bisschen ja und dann hier
noch und denke mir
gut jetzt ja so war man hört direkt
ausgedruckt
[Musik]
geist soweit danach ja jetzt
also ist auf jeden fall sehr intuitiv
habe ich das gefühl macht sehr viel spaß
so machen wir jetzt alle und dann gibt
es noch ein zwei weitere station dann
können wir auch schon wissen produktion
ist im vollen gange ist vita wirklich
richtig spaß daran das fühlt sich echt
ein bisschen 1 findet man so mit knete
spielen also ich drücke dir so ein paar
mal zusammen dass da keine kleinen risse
drin sind dann freue mich so mit den
handballen design so einen kleinen kreis
hausen wenn ich so merke dass sie an den
ecken anfängt aufzubrechen dann mache
ich diese technik dann hat man so diese
schönen ohne risse
[Musik]
das essen ist fast fertig alles steht
bereit wir machen noch schnell den kakao
dazu fertig und wir nehmen pro person
die ist wir sind gleich zu sechs nehmen
wir eine von diesen regeln oder
rollator ohne
mit zimt auf ca und jetzt kommt der
spezielle mut
das sieht so aus wie wenn man selber
feuer mir wird
okay wir machen neben mir eine arbeit ba
noch schön war wirklich wunderbar warm
zugleich kommt hier rein und dann
tauchen
und bin sehr gespannt wie das jetzt
merken
ich fühle mich schon wie ein kolumbianer
war es richtig richtig frau wirklich
geht die hat so ein bisschen knusprig
außen vom grill drin so richtig schön
pfiffig und dieses maismehl hat ihre
eigenen so richtig intensiven geschmack
[Musik]
dass ich kann jetzt schon gericht das
ist so ein frühstück und das ist ja in
vielen ländern ich zum beispiel
amerikanisches frühstück ist ja häufig
richtig schwer und so las vor dem
frühstück dass man jeden tag essen kann
das will man auch jeden tag essen vor
ist das lecker trotzdem total unbekannt
so in dem geschmack so gerade zum
frühstück dem käse tauche ich jetzt
einfach so rein wenn die du willst
kannst du die ganze oder nur ein
bisschen und dann probiert
doch in den käse
also das ist das verrückteste was ich
mir vorstellen konnte es beim frühstück
sagt käser mit cacau
außergewöhnlich dieses süße gemeinsam
mit dem sehr herzhaften seitigen von
cacau musst du dich für zuversicht
projekt sehr lecker das ist das
gewöhnungsbedürftig aber es ist auch gut
also schmeckt auch lecker aber das hier
ist ein no brain für mich das schmeckt
einfach nur krass deshalb bin ich als
das frühstück trinken cacau mit meinem
käse die art passt also wirklich jetzt
schon mit zehn von zehn super leckeres
frühstück und ich freue mich aufs
mittagessen
freunde das recht an ich bin bereit für
das sein kroatischer ich bin sehr
gespannt weil es ist vielleicht auf den
ersten blick nur eine hühnersuppe aber
ich glaube der geschmack wird mich eines
anderen belehren ich freue mich sehr
darauf das ist ein richtiges fest hier
und ich freue mich dabei sein zu können
wir probieren jetzt
[Musik]
ja
und die avocados für nebenbei auf andere
fälle
das ist eine kleine portion ja ok
margarita erstmal vielen lieben dank das
dass du mir das hier angerichtet dass
das ist ja ein traum das haben wir alles
da drin in der suppe was ist da alles
drin kartoffel katze aber wie heißt
diese platte anneliese koch wenn ein
hoch
das ja aber das hier mit tomaten das ist
wie heißt diese paar jahre her ist die
tomate frühlingszwiebel chiligreen
angeles sich zitronig das wichtigste es
ist ganz viel zeit auf wie lange war die
beschäftigt habe schon angefangen im
hassler 96
in columbia ist dann auch noch mal mit
banane aber nicht drehen muss einmal
es wäre ja eigentlich nicht so sehr
banal aber ich werde das salz für die
erfahrung werde ich einmal machen also
wir nehmen eine banane einfach so auf
die seite dann nehme ich meinen löffel
ich nehme ein löffel sofern man weiß von
der banane oder umgekehrt zu helfen
nun ist er auch drin natürlich mehr so
wird man sieht auch diese wunderschönen
fettaugen hier oben auf das sie
glücklich richtig richtig gut ausbeute
brühe an für sich richtig gut die ist
richtig schön kräftig so die wiener
projekt was eine zitrusnoten schmeckt
auch den koriander auf aber sehr dezent
schön straff auch in die erstmalig in
den kolumbianer
[Gelächter]
und ich verstehe es sogar
durch die süße bananen schmeckt die
suppe noch intensiver noch herzhaft aber
es ist richtig richtig lecker also auch
davon hat er schon immer vorgestellt ist
lohnt sich's gut ein beilage
ochsenschwanz joker tor fällt und was
ist das hier oben drauf das war mir
ein bisschen
[Musik]
noch ein wenig reis dazu
ich glaube ich bin jetzt kolumbianer
schmeckt so lecker das schmeckt nicht
dass er ich liebe dich sagen ich
probiere das erst mal alles zu
verdrücken und dann sehen wir uns noch
mal zu meinem fazit zum mittagessen
von anis und du musst ein bisschen
probiert so vielleicht die sankoh schock
verdaut ich hoffe doch ich hoffe dass
mir das hilft zu verdauen
es tut gut nach dem essen ja ich muss
euch wirklich sagen ihr seht beides ist
leer ich habe gekämpft das war wirklich
so ist ja nicht unbedingt wenig aber ich
hätte da glaube ich zwei mal von essen
können von der portion was gut ist
werden wir noch ein abendessen aussicht
aber davor muss nochmals festhalten es
war unfassbar lecker es war unfassbar
abwechslungsreich man konnte ein
bisschen hier ein bisschen davon hat man
noch einen maiskolben es war sehr sehr
interessant so sehr aktiv und es hat
unfassbar gut geschmeckt und umso
gespannter bin ich nach dem frühstück
und mittagessen auch das abendessen und
damit legen wir los
[Musik]
wunderschön also im internet
wirklich weiter da muss ich viel zeit
fürs abendessen ich sitze hier vor
wunderschön goldgelben empanadas dazu
gibt es noch mal ran und das ist ein
etwas gefüllt mit kartoffeln und fleisch
finden sie sehen allein nicht um so
schön aus sie sind gerade oder
präsentieren stehen in diesem moment
hier drüben selben gerade und auf den
kanaren aber ich freue mich sehr darauf
aber ich kann sie auch nur essen weil
sie so lecker aussehen weil ich bin
immer noch wäre noch drei tage sagt
eigentlich von unserem mittagessen
obwohl jetzt ein paar stunden vergangen
sind würde jetzt mal sagen ich weiß eine
ecke und dann muss ich jetzt mal so im
raum
alleine die knusprig schon so die
empanadas und
85 er oder sie wirklich also wirklich so
muss das ist so ein sell street oder was
man auch so sich so nachholen kann wenn
man irgendwie was trinken waren sondern
ist mir also was ich sehe mich so sehr
damit auch hier wieder und man kann gar
nicht so viel dazu sagen und goldgelb
frittiert sind außen richtig krass
knusprig innen drin hast du trotzdem
noch so eine weiche masse und wenn man
dann das du diese frische ag nimmt alles
endstufe es war noch leckerer als ich
gedacht hätte ich wusste schon
kolumbianische küche wird sehr lecker
sein aber was wir heute gesehen haben
ist wirklich krass vom frühstück
mittagessen zum abendessen und ich
könnte also ich könnte jeden tag aus dem
winkel
hier kommt mit entscheiden wer als
nächstes kulinarische reisen denn ich
werde nämlich 3 kommentare schreiben und
der kommentar mit den meisten likes wird
das nächste land deshalb schauten
kommentaren vorbei dank fürs zuschauen
und bis zum nächsten